hey  yes you can't be in here we're closed  oh sorry i'm just i'm hosting the spirit  awards and i'm trying to do like a  promising and woman thing people are  expecting it it's kind of a big movie  this year  and we're kind of closed so you gotta go  really plus you shouldn't be in here  without a mask on  okay yeah and you definitely need a  permit if you wanted to film in here  i know plus the whole set would have to  be coveted compliant that's the whole  thing now  i know i know sanitizer of your coveted  officers  i again i know ah man  if i was wearing a sexy nurse outfit  would that change things  no why would that change things well  because then i'd be an essential worker  i don't think that's how that works fine  you win party pooper cash  hey joel yeah the promising and woman  parody's a no-go  let's just do the sound of metal thing  instead yeah sound of polka  no i don't know what size lighter hosing  i wear joel i can't even say that word